corbin burns on the mound here tonight
for the crew and
like has been the case over his last
handful of starts
jacob nottingham will form the battery
along with him takes care of mirrorfield
on three to open up the ball game
strikeout number one for corbin burns
and as he swings and misses at the
breaking ball yeah good curve ball to
get monday
so back-to-back strikeout couldn't have
asked for a better start for corbin
burns
the 2-2 ground ball to third
and it's a one two three inning for
corbin burns and we'll see how chris
bubich builds on his first big league
victory that was friday at kauffman
stadium against the pirates
and bubitch answers corbin burns
with a three-pitch strikeout against his
first batter no score bottom of the
first nobody on two out
fastball and a high fly ball left field
shallow in comes alex gordon he's got it
and so one two three nothing
doing for the brewers burns is running
in
deals a swinging a rocket to left
and it will be a long single yelich got
to it in a hurry but dozier's aboard
and he got gordon looking three
strikeouts so far that's a backdoor
cutter from
corbin burns burns with two outs gets
ryan o'hearn
struck him out looking another backdoor
cutter for corbin burns
he's got four punch-outs in two innings
kesten
hera monteci goes to second one and
lopez to first
4-2 erasing the lead-off walk
the pitch got him looking
and no argument from tyrone kinder on
that one
lead off batter is on again against
corbin burns second time in his many
innings
there goes heath the throw from
nottingham on the back what a dart from
jacob nottingham
yeah what a throw perfect and give an
assist to corbin burns holding the
runner pretty close
heath he's yet to see the big curveball
threw it right there for strike three
good call whitmer fielding yet to see
the big hook and that seemed like a
decent time to do it
orlando garcia bubitch with a fastball
riding away from arcia and chris has
three strikeouts here's the 3-2 it's
outside
batter nobody it's back-to-back walks
garcia who has been swinging it well
of late ground ball this double play
ball
to second throw to first is offline off
the facing of the dugout
and urias is going to score how about
that a big collision between
monday and lopez at second base
disrupted the throw
i don't see this very often one out for
hunter dozier
there's the slider strikes out dozier
that's his sixth strikeout three and two
on gordon
came all the way back to strike him out
corbin burns
with seven strikeouts through the first
four innings
will face ryan braun and he strikes out
braun with a beautiful
change that is nice that's two and two
on jerkle
[Applause]
first hit of the game for the brewers
jed jerko
takes care of it he's been on base twice
here's ryan o'hearn
the 2-2 struck him out swinging that
time
he looked like a cutter that really
didn't do a whole lot this one right on
the outside corner
it's a 2-2 count boobitch gets his sign
from salvador perez here comes the pitch
and a fastball called strike three on
the inside corner
so make it six strikeouts for bubits
tonight nobody on two down the 3-1 pitch
fastball popped high in the air on the
right side of the infield who wants this
one it's going to be dozier
making the play and there's the second
one 2-3 inning of the night
for chris boob as we go to winning
number six now monday
is struck out and fly to center struck
him out
change up again strikeout number nine
change up at 90.
must be nice this will be pitch number
100 from corbin
burns tapper right to burns
leaps and underhand flip and the inning
is over six
scoreless from corbin burns
garcia against chris boobage he's
allowed only one hit
in the game now he gets a swing and a
miss on a changeup away that was not a
strike and
garcia slams the bat down so
the royals look up and say okay great
corbin burns is out of the game who do
we have
devin williams in his .43 era
change up look at that pitch from devin
williams
from devin williams this is the
change-up
here's the wind and pitch the ground
ball to the left side diving stop urias
gets up throws to first got
a nice pick from jerko outstanding work
on both ends right here
and a short hop no problem for dead
jerko at first base
good defense by the brewers 3-2 swing
and a miss
another nasty change-up from williams a
couple of strikeouts in the inning and
he puts up yet another zero
big insurance run standing at third line
shot right center base head nottingham
delivers again
[Applause]
takes the turn the throw to second not
in time rbi
double jacob nottingham he's come up big
not only catching
really well but coming up with some big
hits that's a huge one they're just
going to put yellow chalk
just put them all and go after ryan
braun
fly ball left center by brawn has he
done it again
you bet three run shot ryan braun he's
broken it open
that's the risk you take when you walk
yelling it's another breaking pitch and
ryan braun waits back
like he knew it was coming number 351 in
his career
trying to finish him off the payoff
struck him out
swinging and the brewers have shut out
kansas city
three straight wins for the brewers and
this one was all about the bees rock